What are you about updates for frequencies?
Do we do this and how often?
So there's value in updating your frequencies
from true right, but a fairly regular basis
if you're running other programs on the right,
other than your program.
So if you're the kind of person,
it's like, all I run is the programs
that Dr. Connor spades for me.
Whether there is never a reason to update
the frequencies on your right, never.
So, but if you're the kind of person
that is like, oh my gosh, I run the other frequencies
all the time if I have another issue
or somebody in the family has got an issue
they're running other programs on the right all the time.
Well, then there's value in updating the frequencies.
And I would do it more than once every month or two.
Realistically, if you don't run that many programs
other than your programs, maybe every three to six months,
this like a trip is an updating them that frequently.
So if you do update the frequencies on your right,
if you have to go to our website and you can click go
right there and click that and type in the search updating
frequencies and we give you a tutorial
on how to do that.
It's quite simple.
All you do is gotta connect your computer
to your Wi-Fi in your house.
You gotta get it connected to internet.
And then all you do is on the right,
go up in the right hand side,
open up any right program.
Well, but the right hand side says update frequencies.
Click on that and it'll start downloading an update.
So, but prior, you know, so like I update my frequencies
about every three to six months at our house,
but we have some patients that have updated their frequencies
in five years because they don't run any other programs.
So then there's really no need to.
Always, if you're going to do the update,
make sure you put your computer back on airplane mode
so that you take it off of Wi-Fi again.
So that's the number one computer problem
is having your computer connected to the internet
because it'll try to download
and Brazilian things that you don't want.